sur un record de participants pour cette
et cauterets 2018 ils étaient plus de
2500 courageux à s'être inscrits au
départ du 80 km depuis l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
objectif rejoindre le premier étage de
la tour eiffel c'est sympa c'est une
bonne ambiance
j'irais pas jusqu'a dire qu'on est entre
locaux mais c'est le plus collectif des
sports individuels que je connais ont
fait un bout de route avec quelqu'un on
le lâche sans recours avec quelqu'un
d'autre c'est sympa comme tous les
participants qui ont dû faire face à des
températures glaciales proche des 0
degré pour combattre ces conditions
climatiques chaque trailer assez
technique à au mental avec un bon petit
coup de vent et puis bah se réchauffer
entre entre coureurs entre coureurs de
froid le froid et vain du coup
l'alimentation aussi s'alimenter et
s'hydrater régulièrement pour ne pas
avoir une mousse sur la fin autre
difficulté un terrain très gras dès les
premiers mètres sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
en effet des zones qui sont assez
inondées justement avec beaucoup de
flaques d'eau et là ça va être un peu
compliqué sur certains passages des
conditions compliquées qui n'ont pas
refroidi le vainqueur de l'épreuve
emmanuel meyssat tu ce sportif de
l'extrême a bouclé les 80 km en 6 heures
et 59 secondes
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition